actuellement et on vous en a parlé hier
soir se déroule à l'hôtel de ville de
paris le congrès des maires de france
mais les élus locaux vont avoir dès la
semaine prochaine leur premier salon au
cnit à la défense et en avant première
une exposition de toutes les figures de
marianne symbole de la république est
organisée dans l'aérogare d'orly ouest
bernard ségara jacques faisant nous
habituer à une marianne espiègle qui
félicite au contraire réprimant nos
hommes politiques
en fait la première marianne est apparue
en 1848 le 24 février jour de
proclamation de la république elle foule
à ses pieds des chaînes brisées et tient
auprès d'elle un symbole d'égalité
marianne en armes cette marianne en
plomb date de la commune le sein
découvert caractéristiques de la
révolution voici une marianne en bronze
maçonnique avec les sharks brodé de
trois dates 789 1848 et 1870 marianne en
biscuit d'un jeu albert l'une des deux
marianne officielle de la troisième
république avec une tête de lion symbole
de la puissance
marianne de poissons autre version
officielle de la troisième république
et voici la marianne de sault pixels de
la quatrième une marianne robuste scène
énergique et humaines celles ci figure
et autrefois la mairie de chamalières le
buste a été remplacé par celui de
l'éffigie de brigitte bardot d'asl ans
mireille mathieu a elle aussi inspiré le
même sculpteur mais c'est une jeune
danseuse du châtelet qui a posé pour
paul belmondo la dernière mariani connu
a pris les traits de catherine deneuve
et puis va bientôt naître la marianne
d'or dans le cadre de méric sco le
premier salon des élus locaux
la marianne c'est le symbole des
collectivités locales c'est le symbole
d'une mairie alors nous avons décidé en
cette année du centenaire de décerner à
dix collectivités locales une marianne
d'or véritable oscars pour remettre et
pour une commune nous allons primés 10
municipalités qui ont innové en matière
de gestion d'équipements ou d'animation
enfin débarquant de l'avion un visiteur
de marque est venu saluer ses dame
respectable
donc j'ai toujours eu un faible pour
pour brigitte quoi tout au moins dans
son jeune temps voilà enfin bravo quand
même allez je file prendre la 0 0